on that note we're going to make our
sunshine app a hundred times better now
by connecting it over the network to the
open weather map service open weather
map provides a free weather data and
forecast API and the site is linked
below so you can follow along by
scrolling through the site you can see
what type of data is available
it also has example queries so you can
click on this one to see what the
weather is like in London it includes a
user-friendly description of the weather
condition such as broken clouds in this
case and we'll use this later in our app
for the full list of weather conditions
you can go back to the main page and
scroll down and then click on this link
here for the weather condition codes and
on this page we have the full list of
weather conditions it contains
everything from scattered clouds to
freezing rain or even volcanic ash I
don't know about you but hopefully that
doesn't happen too often